previously on TV since she's a woman
[Laughter]
[Applause]
episode opens on eyes opening cliche is
it though her hairstyle is clearly cut
the center of her hair and inch and a
half shorter than the rest also for
anyone whose aesthetic demands symmetry
everything is not fine these two plants
are very different from each other also
also how is she so relaxed if I came to
consciousness sitting on a bland couch
facing a wall with script on it
my subconscious will be flapping
horror-movie red flag warnings the size
of jumbo jets I learn a lot about a
character based on what they're wearing
just jacket this tie and this pocket
square pattern tell me that this guy's a
[ __ ] in cases of traumatic or
embarrassing deaths we erase the memory
to allow for a peaceful transition if
this is for the purpose of giving the
deceased a peaceful transition and why
even give the option of letting them
hear about their death just say you died
in your sleep er while having sex with
Jack Shephard unless of course nothing
is as it seems and everything in the
show will get turned on its head
multiple times with brilliant twists and
turns can you imagine if a sitcom were
to put that much thought into it huh you
were in a grocery store parking lot you
dropped a bottle of something called
lonely gal margarita mix for one is
products that only exist in the world of
a sitcom or dramedy because in real life
naming something as sad and distasteful
as that would ruin its market value and
I'm sure you'll bring up potpourri and
I'll ask you to kindly suck my balls
there's a lot of frozen yogurt places
people love frozen yogurt I don't know
what to tell you and I don't either a DB
Russell because frozen yogurt is the
bastard stepchild of the bastard
stepchild of ice cream and is 100% of
sit down here gather round and grab a
chair and get cozy with your neighbour
because it's exposition movie time only
the people with the very highest scores
the true cream of the crop get to come
here to the good place so in this
version of the afterlife heaven is a
magnet school where all my friends will
get in but I'll be stuck at the place
where I'm sitting by a kid who smells
like magic marker and pee sounds about
right
holy I'm a make it to the good place
after all this place I'm out
also genocide is apparently negative 433
thousand Life Points
ending slavery was worth positive eight
hundred fourteen thousand two hundred
ninety two points I'm just saying
someone who wanted to game a system like
this could do both at the same time and
come out almost four hundred thousand to
the positive seems like a pretty nasty
loophole to meet also also kind of
ridiculous place thinks you can put a
value on actions without understanding
or appreciating the context well is this
some sort of sin count for utopia that
has every blade of grass planned to
perfection they don't seem to care about
the back row that can't see from behind
the tree so who's in the bad place that
would shock me I mean it's a Dean Koontz
novel that's 417 pages so I'm sure lots
of people every US president except
Lincoln that sounds about right it does
let's add Millard Fillmore ever do to
you
most people don't make it here but you a
lawyer who got innocent people off death
row that's interesting my real question
is why does she get the architect as her
tour guide all day there were several
other people on their first day in the
GP as well is it because she thought
it's because she's hot isn't it I'm
actually speaking French this place just
translates whatever you say into a
language the other person can understand
man Star Trek really is the gift of
universal language barrier convenience
that just keeps on giving isn't it why
can't I say for if you're trying to
curse you can't hear I guess a lot of
people in this neighborhood don't like
it so it's prohibited it's a full shirt
dog right it forking is what a bunch of
sure dating Pisces also does that mean
if everyone decided Michaels outfits
were offensive he would have to change
also also why not let people cuss as
they please
the afterlife's translation abilities
good fill in a g-rated word for whomever
is listening I want to hear Kristen Bell
cuss like a sailor and NBC's TV PG
rating is core porking my dreams
everyone have a huge house except me
there's really that big of a deal I mean
you know what they say about people with
huge houses they have lots of furniture
yeah big house people you poked me
that's fine not as much fun as I was
having in my head when Kristen Bell said
to Jameela Jamil that she booked her do
you a second to talk about the
environment do you have a second to eat
my farts cussing Queen would never save
my farts in her real life she'd say
shove that nature pamphlet up your
puckered would eat milady which is what
my college girlfriend said to me after
our intro to environmental ethics
orientation I spent
my life in North Korea fighting for
women's rights and the other half in
Saudi Arabia fighting for gay rights
people who exaggerate are the worst
I've done the math and after graduating
from school this man spent maybe 10
years to serve each cause a decade is
not the same thing as half my life
cheerful face liar I have been in
oppresses for over 200 years and my boss
has finally given me my first solo
project so basically they took the least
interesting storyline from season 6 of
How I Met Your Mother and turned it into
a show you're a nice person
Cheney and Conda agonal come on go and
they're gone yeah I'm gonna grande
Ariana Grande
that's a person I did it damn it I am
really having a fun time with the show
Kristen Bell is a national treasure
this is all happening because of you
fork fork fork was fun for a flash but
fretfully fading fast hey how do I make
that helper woman show up but don't you
know how to do it since you summon her
at the honeys party to help you get
drunk a book on how to act good I
believe you mean how to act well
cheating yeah probably have to get
myself a sin for that what it caught but
I'd say it's like 50 million
simultaneous orgasm better I realize
she's being exaggerated but wouldn't
just about everything be better than
that I saw that house episode where the
woman couldn't stop orgasming and it
didn't end well didn't think I'd have to
be researching does the dog die dot-com
for a show called the good place but
here we are flying oh you wanted to do
was talk about morals I mean you're like
is the worst part of Superman actually
that would be Zack Snyder but we can let
GT be second I'm not a mountain of
strength I'm a canyon full of poo-poo a
canyon of poo-poo I collected the worst
smelling garbage that I could find do
you still want me to dump it inside of
Antonio's house can it offers so much
plot convenience they should have just
named her plot comp or cloak Oh block
and then knit
look but don't touch
but don't taste taste don't swallow cool
cool I'm an architect but please call me
Larry people in your neighborhood do a
second to talk about the environment do
you have a second to eat my shields
[Music]